when it comes to training
this is something we've talked about on
the podcast before
uh and i want to frame it as a very
specific problem statement because this
is how a lot of people approach it
so
i'm not cutting yet you know i'm about
as strong as i've ever been i'm
performing well fueling my workouts
everything's going well congrats dude
yeah thank you
and right now for some random exercise
i'm able to do four sets of eight with
about 200 pounds
uh and you know
you know that might fluctuate day to day
it might be a slight positive uh you
know trajectory because i'm doing
progressive overload and not everyone
can do dealt raises with that much
weight but eric's a freak uh but anyway
so i'm able to do four by eight with 200
pounds
as this cut progresses
most likely there's going to be a point
where i can no longer do four sets of
eight with 200 pounds uh depending on
how aggressive the cut is and how much
ground i'm trying to cover but i might
get to a point where now if i'm using
200 pounds i'm only able to do
eight and then six and then five and
five you know instead of eight eight
eight
so a lot of people within that problem
statement say
what what's my best strategy here should
i
for example reduce set volume am i
trying to do too many sets in my
workouts and it's you know because i
have lower recovery capacity should i
keep the load that i'm using and instead
of trying to do sets of eight maybe i'm
trying to do sets of six you know
so should i be or should i keep trying
to do four sets of eight with the same
relative difficulty and drop the load so
instead of doing four by eight with 200
now i'm doing it with 185 and it's going
okay
so the question is what do i do here uh
to
most
effectively preserve my strength or
preserve my fat free mass and
specifically with this i want to talk
about fat free mass
so
should i be dropping the rep range a
little bit should i be dropping some set
volume should i be dropping the load to
make this a little bit more feasible uh
this is a question we've talked about
before and
uh we've mentioned how we're
both kind of a bit surprised that
there's simply not direct research on
this that we're aware of yeah that
really really specifically shows if
you're cutting
here is the blueprint blueprint for
managing your training variables to best
retain
muscle mass or fat free mass like
to our knowledge that doesn't exist yeah
we don't even have
one blueprint and in other fields they
have the blueprint two the blueprint
three perfect we're we're really behind
in this area um so yeah we've talked
about this before on the show we've said
listen if you want an evidence-based
statement i don't have much for you if
you want kind of a practical applied
statement that involves some speculation
you know my personal approach in this
situation is
i
generally as a cut starts getting really
brutal i start to reduce my repetition
ranges a little bit and i start to cut
my set volume a little bit especially
for some of the ancillary
kind of uh
you know my assistance exercises or my
auxiliary exercises
uh because what i notice is first of all
you start getting like let's say the the
the experience i'm drawing on here is
deep into a contest prep
uh i don't have the glycogen to give you
a good set of i certainly not to give
you four good sets of 12. right it's not
there i'm cutting my carbs are low it's
just gone and so in that context i like
to drop my rep ranges so that i can
at least lean harder on my phospho
creatine system
and my glaring lack of glycogen won't
become quite as apparent in my
performance of my exercises
so i like to
make my rep ranges a little bit more
compatible with the energy systems that
i can still kind of reliably lean on
i dropped my set volume because like if
you've ever had a high volume program
you start to know when you're getting
into what some people would colloquially
call junk volume where at a certain
point you're like why am i still in the
gym like this is this is kind of
nonsense what i'm doing here yeah when
you're deep into prep you reach that
point pretty early in a workout if you
try to maintain the same number of
exercises and sets and yeah if you keep
everything the same
that point where you start to say am i
actually doing anything here it comes a
lot earlier in the workout so for that
reason i like to drop my set volume a
little bit so that i'm
being as efficient as i can with really
high quality effort in the gym
and
there is some evidence to suggest uh
that when it comes to change to gains in
fat free mass and muscle mass uh you
know the volume it took to build that
muscle may not necessarily be as much as
it takes to maintain that muscle uh you
know there there have been
fairly long term longitudinal trials
where they have a muscle building phase
where they gain some muscle with a
relatively higher volume program and
they can actually maintain it pretty
effectively when they cut that volume
down a little bit as long as intensity
remains high so for that cluster of
reasons
my general approach would which i would
not say is like conclusively the best
way to do it
but the way that i find most favorable
is to
trim my repetition ranges a little bit
and cut my set volume a little bit
especially for some of the less critical
exercises in my program